Donald Trump ran on having the most
transparent administration in history
part of transparency is having press
briefings Donald Trump's last press
secretary Stephanie Grisham had zero
that's not a typo zero press briefings
not a single press briefing during her
tenure the point of the press secretary
is to bridge the gap between what Trump
is thinking and doing and planning and
the press and Stephanie Grisham held
zero press briefings she was recently
replaced by Caylee Mackin Annie or
McKenna knee take your pick she had her
first press briefing on Friday we
covered it live as it was happening and
it was a house of horrors I will spare
you a lot of the absolutely meaningless
answers she gave which had no substance
but I want to focus on one thing she was
asked during the press briefing will you
pledge never to lie to us never to lie
to the press and she said yes I will
never lie to you and then she lied her
way through the entire press briefing
let's start with that question coming
from the the press corps will you lie to
us and she looked absolutely dazed the
entire press conference one of the
strangest ones I've seen but here is her
answer about lying are you planning to
do these at this point and also pledged
never to lie to us from that podium I
will never lies here you have my word on
that as to the timing of the briefings
we do plan to do them I pledge not to
lie to you and then she spends the
entire press briefing line let's take a
brief tour of the lies she claimed for
example that the Moller report was a
total exoneration of donald trump at a
lot of your papers I've seen a whole lot
of scant information about Michael Flynn
when there was a whole lot of
speculation about Russia Russia Russia
culminating in 40 million dollars of
taxpayer money being lost in the
complete and total exoneration of
President Trump thank you guys so much
this is an acute provable lie Robert
Moeller actually said if we could have
exonerated Donald Trump on obstruction
of justice
we would have said it so it is a direct
lie that the molar report was an
exoneration of Trump McEnaney also said
that the molar investigation cost 40
million that's a popular Trump is
talking point even Trump has said it the
truth is the costs of the investigation
were 32 million but it recovered
according to one report 42 million it
recovered according to another report 46
million so the molar report recovered
more money than it cost
she also said not a single ventilate not
a single American has died for lack of a
ventilator Trump has been saying that
it's really hard to know if that's true
for sure but we have reporting that
multiple people had to be placed on one
ventilator which you're not supposed to
do we know that a terminally ill person
had to be removed from a ventilator to
put someone with coronavirus on it we
know that some hospitals did have
rationing decisions to make about
ventilators so we certainly can't say
for sure that no one died due to a lack
of ventilators big lie on Michael Flynn
Donald Trump's convicted former national
security adviser Caylee Mackin Annie
said that there was a handwritten FBI
note that said we need to get Flynn to
lie and they are alleging that this
means that there was a sort of perjury
trap set up all this is is interrogators
planning an interrogation interrogators
already knew Flynn had lied and they
were trying to get the lies on the
record that's all it is they are trying
to make it out to be some smoking gun
and it's not now last thing on this what
the White House press corps should have
asked Kayleigh and they didn't ask her
about this is that she went on TV in
February and she said President Trump
isn't like Obama President Trump will
never let the coronavirus come to the
United States here are her words don't
take my word for it absolutely this
president will always put America first
he will always protect American citizens
we will not see diseases like the corona
virus come here we will not see
terrorism come here and isn't that
refreshing when contrasting it with the
awful presidency of President Obama
Caylee mcenamey thank you so much
good to see you thank you that's what
Kayleigh mackaninee should be asked
about and I hope she will be Kayleigh
you told us in February that Trump would
never allow coronavirus to come here
we now have 1.2 million cases and our
death rate is the 14th highest in the
world can you admit you were wrong about
Donald Trump that's the question that
should be asked it wasn't hopefully we
will see it asked in the future make
sure you're following the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show I
want to give a quick shout out to one of
our sponsors VIN Charo watches they're
giving my audience 15% off your entire
order when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch maybe you don't usually wear
a watch and you've been thinking about
looking for one to elevate your look or
you've been thinking about replacing the
one you have check out VIN Charo it's an
American company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look amazing and they
look like something you'd spend a lot of
money on but ever even Cheryl watch
ranges from a hundred and fifty to three
hundred dollars I went on their website
and picked out the Kyros in white and
silver really love the look the
combination of the white face and the
beige band really love this one they
also sent me the Kairos limited release
gold reserve set totally different style
this one would make a fantastic gift for
a couple people I can think of in my
family any time you see me wearing a
watch on the show I'm wearing a Ventura
watch go through their collection I know
you'll find something you like and
you'll get 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch